so there is no secret in the cylinder the
secret is in the hands over the
years I have tried to perfect it in fact
from a roll of dough I can
get 256 threads so thin that I
am perhaps the only one who can make
these 256 threads
[Music
] my name paola brain and I dedicate myself to
this pasta called su ville in
dio that I have been working for over 40 years
field a director and since the dawn of time
therefore an ancient pasta that we
only work on the wall the ingredients of the
god feeling seem  durum wheat, water and
salt and then either I proceed with this
movement of the hands where I fold the
dough eight times in order to create
these very thin threads to be placed on
the wooden bottom
after which it starts to dry in the sun
when there is a beautiful day or  at
home inside the house at
room temperature
there is no machine that can
produce it is a pasta that is processed
only and exclusively by hand and
we will all be a dozen people who
we know how to make this pasta all over the world
, handed down from mother to
daughter,
however it is always a
family tradition that we want to keep in the
family there is no other pasta in the
world like this
[Music]